all right guys there's a lot i want to
talk about in this video a lot you want
to hear about in this video i'm going to
get right to it right thinking the
sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by nordvpn nordvpn's a
vpn service with a core neucopia of
features features of convenience like
letting you change your virtual location
with one click ensuring that you never
miss your favorite content even if
you're overseas but also nordvpn has
solid features of protection nord's
threat protection feature blocks malware
scans downloaded files for viruses it
acts like a shield between you and the
potential hazards of the digital
minefield slash wonderland that is the
internet and this is all risk-free with
nord's 30-day money-back guarantee
even my barking dogs like it so click
the link below go to nordvpn.com
john's get yourself a two-year plan with
a huge discount plus one additional
month for free and thank you once again
to nordvpn for sponsoring this video i
do appreciate it and now i talk about
what you want to hear about which is
heated religious debate no no there's a
spoiler talk for doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness but to be fair
learn this recently if you had one room
full of mormons and catholics and
another room full of mcu fans which room
do you think would have the more heated
debates that end in ire exactly and of
course me being me i'm gonna go head
first right into that room and this is
my doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness spoiler talk this isn't a
play-by-play i'm not going to talk about
every little scene in the movie just
some things that stood out to me things
i couldn't talk about my spoiler-free
review but all right in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness it starts
out there's doctor strange who looks
different than doctor strange but it's
doctor strange so you're like oh
alternate universe doctor strange he's
running with this girl america
[Music]
i'll always think of that and i'll
always make that joke i even saw someone
in the comments section of my
spoiler-free review for doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness i
apologize for this person i'm gonna
paraphrase what you said this is
something along the lines of this movie
was [ __ ] and you have lost your touch
jeremy i was just like
talking about that team america
reference was awesome so anyhow that
strange dies which right there you're
like oh so that's where zombie strange
comes from but he dies and then she rips
through the universe in a star pattern
of course i told you there's some cheese
in the script this is the moment i'm
gonna find out one of two things either
that's how it looked in the comic books
or she doesn't even have that power in
the comic books and it's just completely
made up kind of like how kitty pride
could send people back in time
days of future past where did that power
come from anyhow she comes over to our
world or at the very least the avengers
world not to say it's actually ours
there are no avengers in our world and
before i get to the rest of it there was
actually a really cool scene
it's the only time i've seen this
address and i thought it was awesome and
i i'm kind of sad that i feel like it's
the last time we'll ever see an address
and that's when strange is at his
i'm going to call her rachel mcadams
he's at rachel mcadams characters
wedding and mr sackler sits down next to
him is pretty much like yeah i was dust
too and i lost my cats and i lost my
brother tell me was there any other way
and strange looks kind of awkward and
he's like no it's the only play we had
which i think is great this is a really
compelling thing for me
because you could tell strange is like
no one out there will ever understand
that i saw
millions of other realities and that was
the only one where we won is the burden
of knowledge compared to the short sl i
would call it short-sightedness but
really it's just human nature who
wouldn't be pissed at him it's easy to
hear yeah it's the only play we had but
it's like yeah but i lost people i never
got to say goodbye to them because i was
dust it was a really cool moment again i
feel like it's just never going gonna go
anywhere and i'd like to see that go
somewhere also i'm like how did they
know that he gave the stone to thanos
did tony stark blab i could see that
happening tony stark gets back goes on
twitter all like yeah we had thanos in
the fight and then the circus magician
gave the green rock to the grape of
wrath but you find out these monsters
that are coming after this america
chavez girl it's all part of witchcraft
and so strange is like hey i know
someone who could help out with that
turns out help out ain't the word it's a
very short reveal where she's like oh by
the way yeah this wonderful utopia of
sheep
apple trees it all turns to death she's
like i have my cursed book of evil i was
like
horror tones in an evil book
sam raimi has entered the mcu my friends
you know the funny thing is when america
chavez and strange go to that one
universe you know and everything looks
super futuristic he almost gets hit by a
car because in this alternate universe
red means go green means stop and i was
like
you took that from sliders i believe
that was the pilot episode of sliders
and then doctor strange is like wanda's
out there doing really messed up [ __ ]
maybe i'll have bruce campbell punch
himself for two weeks i mean of course
there was going to be a bruce campbell
cameo great to see it because america
[ __ ] yeah i just jacked a pizza ball and
didn't pay for it instead of talking
this guy off the ledge like aladdin did
he was like i'll just have you punch
yourself for two weeks and the guy was
just pissed off that someone robbed him
you know a thing that did disappoint me
in this movie which i was gonna address
in my spoiler free review but i was like
well if i talk about how mordo didn't do
much and i was disappointed in that then
that implies mordo's
not really a villain process of
elimination could whittle people down to
like oh hey maybe wanda's the villain i
mean more than that [ __ ] tv spot did
what the hell what's up with that why
did they do that yeah i was disappointed
with mordo in this movie for a couple
reasons one because yeah he didn't do
much i was pumped to see mordo back and
you know it left off it was the end of
doctor strange the first one was the
post-credits scene where he was like oh
i'm gonna kill wizards now apparently
doctor strange says oh mordo did that he
he vowed to destroy me
i'm like well how do you know that is
there
is there a doctor strange 1.5 like a
movie that takes place in between these
two movies where you just kind of faced
that the point is this mordo isn't that
mortal this is a mortal from another
universe so this mortal really has no
build up everything that happened in the
first doctor strange
it's unlinked to this guy then there's
the illuminati we're starting to get
into realms where this is where the
movie disappointed people from the
chatter i've seen in the comment section
it's the illuminati was wasted
and um wanda for a couple reasons now
wanda i'll talk about in a sec but the
illuminati i won't lie don't know much
about them in the comic books don't know
much about the illuminati other than the
general concept like in life
the theory or is it a theory and what i
saw in angels and demons and that's it
court of owls counts as the illuminati
so i'll throw that in there like gotham
illuminati it counts and they should
totally do that in the batman too that
would be pretty awesome but as for the
illuminati i was like kill him kill him
kill her kill her oh reed richards i
mean that was cool though you can't
escape the internet and as much as i try
to minimize
internet spoilers there's always a video
out there where it's like oh rumor is
john krasinski is going to be reed
richards and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness i know it's where
some people make their bread and butter
on youtube i totally get it i just hate
that i run across it that said i think
he'd make a fine reid richards also
charles xavier we saw that in the first
trailer with sir patrick stewart's voice
1 000 we should tell him the truth [ __ ]
you logan and all the things i like
saying in his voice i will you're ready
for command so he comes out but man he
comes out in the wheelchair you know
like the the floaty yellow wheelchair
the danny elfman score starts going
all right movie you're making it very
hard to stay objective because that [ __ ]
is working i feel like that's the disney
overlords i feel like that's their move
they're like obi-wan kenobi trailer put
that music in there that'll just hit him
right in the fields give me that duel of
the fates give me that battle of the
heroes people always ask like why do i
look over that that's my that's my fake
person there's no one there but again
with that tv spot [ __ ] you tv spot what
are you doing so scarlet witch
dreamwalks into this universe and just
tears everyone to [ __ ] what that the
dreamwalking what that is is she
meditates then her consciousness goes
into the body of the wanda maximoff in
that other universe and now she can
control that body and it's basically
it's how she can get around universes
without physically going into that
universe and man man she [ __ ] them yes
dude i don't even care like i loved it i
was like finally this illuminati that
everyone really cares a lot about i'm
sorry for you folks who do but they're
all going to die and i'm pretty happy
because i just want to see blood carnage
death though reed richards was a dumb
ass in that moment telling you some
sloppy script [ __ ] in this movie reed
richards is like alright wanda we get it
you're in pain i have kids i understand
tuning fork head man over here can wipe
you out with one noise from his mouth
just in case you were wondering how to
take him down or stop that from
happening and she's like what mouth and
then it zooms out i'm like holy [ __ ]
dude she just did the matrix she did the
neo man his mouth is gone
i was like
well that was pretty cool everyone ate
[ __ ] man like she took the the captain
america captain carter shield and threw
it through captain carter and sliced her
in half reed richards just kind of got
unwoven like spaghetti kind of reminded
me of what thanos could do to people
where he's just like oh sorry drax your
little sponge squares now but at least
when thanos left he's like all right
you can humpty dumpty yourself back
together again cause i'm nice wanda's
like hey sorry ready set spaghetti
you're dead remember that game
i do are you picking up the keyboard
right now to type jeremy grew up with
ready set spaghetti what the [ __ ]
i did though
i did that's the thing that you know
some people are pissed about like well
they just introduced reed richards and
kill them like you know there's that's
just one universe of reed richards
there's another one out there i mean if
they just canonically roll with it like
nope in the fantastic four movie reed
richards is dead because he died in this
movie i'll be like you are not utilizing
that multiverse concept properly i just
like that scene i do see cracks
happening in the mcu storytelling when
it comes to the multiverse because story
was in the show loki in the series loki
it was like multiverse can't happen but
because of the events of loki because
sylvie killed kang
well he wasn't really kang he was like
he was cool kang he was the crazy uncle
at the party's kang point is it was like
oh because of the events of loki now
there's a multiverse but the tobey
maguire andrew garfield's spider-man
universe has already existed also dreams
you know it's just like dreams are
illustrated in this movie as windows
into other universes so when you dream
what you're seeing in your dream is a
you in another universe i think it's a
really cool concept it's one of those
concepts i feel like most all of us have
all thought about at least once twice or
2 700 times but unless dreams never
existed in the mcu up until the point i
mean if dreams always existed in the mcu
then the events of loki are kind of
useless and again at the events of loki
you know it took place outside of linear
time it's not like oh it just happened
and now those universes exist but
because it was outside of time it just
kind of makes it irrelevant if you took
the show loki out of canon just
canonically wiped it from existence feel
like spider-man no way home and doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
would still make sense anyhow
that's how i'm seeing it oh professor x
dies but if that was a great horror
movie moment you know professor x goes
into wanda's mind and he sees like the
good wanda is like under rocks and he's
like i wonder i'm trying to help you
there's an evil scarlet witch here give
me your hand and the scarlet fog comes
up on professor x and snaps his neck i
guess i'll do the deep dive and talking
about wanda as the villain now i just i
really liked wanda as the villain
because it's so much better than how it
looked like it was going after juan
division one division was like hey you
just mind [ __ ] this entire town
against their will and i said in my one
division finale video that they had the
best setup for an mcu villain but i said
it because i didn't think they'd do it
and they did it and i think that's
awesome that's one of the reasons i
liked her as the villain i feel like
that's the hill i'm going to die on you
know she's like nope i just i like that
she slaughtered a lot of people sorry
that you're mad about that but i liked
it i've also seen the argument that she
takes the shine away
from doctor strange in his own movie but
doctor strange is still the protagonist
she's the antagonist i mean to be fair
to that point thanos did the same thing
to the avengers in an avengers movie the
movie was titled avengers infinity war
who's the coolest character in the movie
exactly thanos yeah thanos stood out
thanos stole the show i love it when
villains do that man just it doesn't
happen too often usually it's the hero
show and yeah we have this person who's
causing problems
but it's really the hero's show and in a
world where the argument for thanos was
oh we understand where thanos is coming
from don't really we don't we just we
see
how he got there but we still see the
flaws in the argument you know same with
wanda for me i see how she got to the
point where she's like nope i want to go
back to the happy place i want to be
with my children i dream about them
which means they're out there in other
universes and i'm going to get there but
yeah going to do all the wrong things to
do it can definitely be a villain doing
it but there's definitely a face your
mortality story going in there you know
i mean if you had a device a macguffin a
person or otherwise superpower out there
that could get you back to those happy
days
wouldn't you do it and how far would you
go there's a fascinating conversation in
this movie there just i don't know kind
of hit me and that tipped her you know
it's like madness is like gravity all it
takes is a little push that that pushed
her over the edge well that in a cursed
book that corrupted her anyhow i liked
wanda as a villain i liked how savage
she was as a villain yeah she goes out
basically just
pulling a roof down on her head she
breaks the support beams and this whole
temple just
i guess she's dead i mean it's a world
of magic who knows maybe she's alive but
if we're talking about a villain who was
a good person who then was corrupted by
a thing who then became a villain and
then busted the supports down causing
the super antagonist structure to come
down on top of them killing them in the
process i liked it when it was doctor
octopus in spider-man 2. so suppose i
like it when it's wanda funny because
america [ __ ] yeah i was like all right
she opens a portal she's like i wanted
to hear your kids and she freaks her
kids out well i was not her kids other
wanda's kids but those are the kids she
was gonna you know mother i don't know
kill her other self pointed she was
gonna be the stand-in mom to these kids
and these kids were like ah you're a
witch and i've seen the argument like
why doesn't she just open another portal
to another place and then she could just
you know not look so evil and not freak
those kids out but i don't think it was
that you know it was the fact that her
kids looked at her like a monster got
her to internalize and be like oh [ __ ] i
am a [ __ ] monster i know this because
i've really done monstrous things you
know that because we all saw it i mean
wanda wrecking fools i don't even care
oh god
i love it and that's when she put her
magic on the four posts and was like i
will not die a monster
so i guess america chavez is going to
become a wizard now so she can traverse
the multiverse and become a wizard
that's some pretty busted superpower
which is funny when she was like oh i
only react to make these portals i can't
make them happen i thought doctor
strange is gonna take her up to mount
everest and be like trust me this lesson
works
see you later i mean that's what i would
have done
bunny i went all this way i didn't even
talk about zombie strange because like i
mean yeah i guess zombie strange is in
it so he dream walks into that body and
that's like where the big throwdown
happens as for post-credit scene i miss
when it was like oh it's thor's hammer
and that's the post credit scene i know
what that is samuel l jackson being like
i'm here to talk to you about the
avengers initiative and being like
there's no way they're gonna pull that
off but i do get the reference this one
shirley starring shows up and i swear
this is my thought i was like
was she in eternals
i don't remember and even saying it now
i can only tell i don't think she was
but i definitely know this
[ __ ] knows if i know who she is oh god
those books right so there's a there's a
super bad book and a super good book and
i guess the super good book will give
you anything you need to defeat your
enemy it's like room of requirement in
book form i guess so i've heard but we
never really saw it it's like they got
this book and it didn't really do
anything it's like the whole fetch quest
was all for [ __ ] might be one of
those things that's in the 2 hour 40
minute cut of this movie yeah i guess
this movie has a 2 hour 40 minute cut
initially that raymie had uh which is
funny it's like the bvs effect with
batman versus superman my initial
thoughts when i saw the theatrical
version of the movie i was like that
movie could have been shorter they could
have cut some things out but when things
aren't fleshed out my natural
inclination anyways like yeah they
should just cut that out i guess but on
the other hand the other option is if
you have footage and scenes on the
cutting room floor that fleshes all that
out yeah put that in there and then you
don't have to cut it out like batman
versus superman the director's cut was
like three hours long and much better so
i guess there's that i don't even know
if we're ever gonna see that two hour 40
minute cut
i'd like to just out of curiosity i'd
like to see it i just want to see what
it was i mean it might be much worse
might be like oh god there's a reason
this was cut down to two hours and what
is it six minutes or something look in
the end doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness is it the smoothest ride no
but it's a movie i enjoyed because of
the standout villain that is scarlet
witch in a world that's littered with
boring [ __ ] ass mcu villains anytime
there's a villain that stands out and
yes is a scene stealer dude i'll take it
so is this a spoiler video i couldn't
ask you this before as i leave you now
i'll ask you now wanda as the villain
how does that sit with you what do you
like about it what do you not like about
it what do you love about it what do you
hate about it whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you